le journal au moins il a alors le
scandale de danse avec les stars dans
danse avec les stars arielle dombasle a
signé pour quatre prime et après c'est
elle qui décidera si elle part ou si
elle reste alors c'est sûr donc ceux de
l'année prochaine c'est son corps son
dernier oui oui oui mais voilà ça ce
dernier est atteint c'est elle qui
décide d'un corps mois après celle je
suis dit on en attendait je suis sûr de
ça d'accord j'ai bossé tout le week-end
la langue lors du prime où il ya eu la
première élimination c'est elle qui
devait partir - elle pouvait pas partir
comme à la signer pour 4 ils ont viré
vincent cerrutti qu'non cette semaine là
cette semaine
oui ça allait se reproduire pour éviter
qu'elle ne parte les juges ont attribué
leurs 20 points arielle dombasle
personne n'a compris c'est pour éviter
qu'elles soient virés par les votes
voilà et donc qu'ils ont viré hapsatou
sy et pourquoi ils l'ont venir est pas
parce qu elle était dernière parce
qu'elle est sur ces 8es sally's ennuyait
de faire de la promo de quelqu'un qui
habite à première vue le scoop ne les
intéresse pas des comptes attention pour
ceux qui comprennent un peu l'espagnole
imac alors moi oui mais là sinon je dis
va te dire public sebha et jean michel
aulas ça sème le trouble parce qu'on
voit ces arguments ça c'est vrai pour
une fois qu'il n'y pas de kolda oui
enfin c'est maxime guen il en a pris le
relais vers l'un plein la poire sera
fait ou si c'est vrai qu'il n'ya plus
d'histoire à raconter entre elles et
vincent cerruti donc ça aussi c'est un
élève se débarrasser d'un peu d'argent
quand tu dis que arielle dombasle a été
éliminé j'appelle et éliminer la
première semaine ça veut dire que
c'était truqué pour vincent sollicité
sur une toile alors là j'ai mis au
conditionnel mais je suis quasiment sûr
is it est atteinte en cité c'est grave
comme très grave c'est pour ça que j'ai
mis un conditionnel et sienna et damien
conditionne pour ceux qui connaissent un
petit peu la grammaire un site et un
joint veux me démentir s'ils me montrent
les votes